ce tract les chiens formés au final tous
cas en affirmant que le gouvernement
fédéral allait appuyer financièrement le
projet trans manten justin trudeau à
faire réagir l'opposition
le conflit est devenue une vraie crise
dans un tweet le chef conservateur un
duo chez eux ajoute avant l'arrivée de
justin trudeau au pouvoir les projets
énergétiques allait de l'avant sans
l'appui de fonds publics
mais était ce vraiment le cas en 1988 à
l'époque des progressistes-conservateurs
de brahim journée le gouvernement
fédéral a donné plus d'un milliard de
dollars en subventions pour le
développement de la plateforme hibernia
situé au large de terre-neuve
bref des subventions fédérales à
l'industrie pétrolière il en existe
depuis des décennies il y en a eu sous
les libéraux et les conservateurs à la
fin des années 2000 des groupes
écologistes les estimés à près de trois
milliards de dollars par année
il faudrait qu'en 2009 au sommet du g20
à pittsburgh
le gouvernement harper s'est engagé à
éliminer progressivement d'autres
subventions inefficaces aux combustibles
fossiles
justin trudeau a pris le même genre
d'engagement lors de la dernière
campagne électorale
sauf que l'an dernier le vérificateur
général du canada
il a démontré que le gouvernement
fédéral n'avait toujours pas identifié
les subventions qui devait être éliminé
[Musique]